moi je dois dire que je suis en état de
choc encore je suis je suis dans un état
d'épuisement physique psychologique qui
est avancé je ne souhaite même à mon
pire ennemi de vivre ce qu'on vient de
vivre la sueur sur 24 heures hier après
midi j'étais en réunion de groupe à
l'assemblée nationale la première
réunion de groupe avec avec les tous les
élus insoumis et un moment donné à 15
heures je vois tomber l'info sur les
réseaux et là je récupère je récupère de
l'article parce qu'il était payant donc
bon il fallait d'abord que je le
récupère et la jolie mais je n'en
revenais pas c'est à dire qu'en fait
j'ai une personne sans papiers d'origine
algérienne aurait promener mon enfant
aurait été interpellé par la police avec
mon enfant
et je le disais mais c'est quoi ça c'est
quoi parce que c'est ça n'existe pas si
quelqu'un est interpellé avec votre
enfant ou on vous appelle la police
social interpelle quelqu'un est votre
encontre vous appelle déjà pour
n'importe quel citoyen alors imaginez
pour
aux équipements du tout au courant de
l'info alors le journaliste par
journalistes le personnel ne pas
utiliser ce terme pour cette personne
c'est la personne de la fp à la base non
non mais c'est un journal iran parce que
non il ya pire le journaliste dit que
pour lui voilà vous allez voir je vais
vous dire ce que je vous dirai pour ce
qu'il a fait alors oui allez-y zemmouri
et un est un est un est un salarié du
magazine le point depuis de très
nombreuses années allemand il donne de
bonnes infos non ça fait quand même cinq
fois qu'il est condamné pour diffamation
donc oui mais pas dire ou alors en
général et il m'avait écrit lundi en fin
de journée un sms en me disant mal
bonjour madame la députée vous embaucher
une personne sans papiers est ce que
vous avez l'intention de faire des
démarches pour la régulariser et c'était
déjà un message qui m'étaient adressés à
partir d'une boîte mail donc je trouvais
ça étrange donc déjà j'ai fait un petit
ride pour vérifier que c'était bien lui
je lui ai écrit ensuite à son vrai
numéro en lui disant c'est n'importe
quoi c'est vraiment n'importe quoi
j'ai pas en fait de femmes ménagères
depuis déménageurs de penta d'année et
là pendant la campagne j'ai eu recours à
de l'aide et ça a donné lieu
systématiquement des déclarations urssaf
c'était des personnes qui avaient le
droit de travailler point c'était ma
réponse je l'avais eu qu'une seule
question qui portait sur ce point madame
la députée est ce que vous avez fait des
démarches pour régulariser
la personne n'y avait aucune question
sur prétendument la scolarisation des
enfants à paris sur prétendument le fait
que j'avais un logement à paris sur
prétendument le fait que cette personne
était soi-disant ans dans les cadences
infernales travaillé jour et nuit que
soit disant qu'elle vivait chez moi
mais on a vu qu'on avait les sms passés
voilà où
c'est quoi ces c'est fou tout ça bien
sûr c'est faux que ce à quoi il faut
alors été inventé pour ça que nous avec
alexis ont rédigé enfin bon moi j'étais
vraiment mais on aurait pris le temps de
rédiger la une réponse pour réfuter et
la lui sur twitter est réel mais en
mettant des captures d'écran de
certaines radios pierre
bonsoir c'est la même
forêt par le bas et qu'on appelle un
médecin
ça va chaque son chaque soir c'est pas
heureusement qu'on n'a pas signé voilà
par l'autoroute avant mais ça va vous
sinon je sais que la seule chose que je
vous demande de contaminer nidal fini
feliz en irak est alors à canon mais
c'est fou quand même te rends compte que
tu mets quand ils ont inventé tout ça
moi enfin à qui profite le crime et oui
c'est vrai en tout cas le savez très
bien que ça allait sortir très vite avec
koné avait nagé vite dit que c'était
faux le professeur kouassi zemmouri fait
ça pourquoi en fait c'est difficile à
dire loin de la boutique nice un
journaliste plutôt de tank et
d'investiguer la préfecture va ouvrir
l'oeil et les dossiers pollution en
général c'est ce qui fait mais c'est fou
et donc effectivement on s'était dit est
ce que je me suis posée est-ce que c'est
pas un coup monté qui regardent des
secteurs syndicaux policiers parce que
c'est vrai que c'est nos toits que les
relations entre certains syndicats de
police d'extrême droite et la france est
soumise sont déplorables sauf que sauf
qu'avec les enquêtes parce qu'il ya eu
un tas de journalistes qu'ils sont bien
enquêté d'abord jeu quand même remercier
vraiment du fond du coeur les citoyens
les internautes et les journalistes qui
ont tout de suite commencé à faire les
vérifications notamment des bunkers par
exemple le faut de la capture d'écran
par sms ça tout de suite j'ai même pas
eu besoin de le faire c'est à dire ça
s'est fait tout de suite par la
communauté en ligne les gens ont fait
les analyses ont passé les ont passés
les images au crible et ils ont dit
c'est totalement c'est totalement
feuilletage ensuite les journalistes y
en a eu trois en particulier un à
libération vincent caucase un
mediapart david perrotin est un as au
monde antoine antonioni évidemment avec
leur équipe parce qu'ils se sont mis à
plusieurs ont commencé à chercher et je
m'aperçois du coup que 1 la préfecture
de police n'a pas de nouvelles d'une
interpellation aucune en faut rien y
remonter il n'y a pas de y'a pas de
d'autres dossiers il n'y a pas de deux
procès verbal ya pas de mains courantes
gardien alors que bon on peut penser que
dans le cas d'une interpellation d'une
personne sans papiers ça remonte pas
systématiquement au préfet mais quand il
s'agit de l'enfant d'un député qui a
interpellé avec une personne sans
papiers qui en plus allégret être exclue
parce qu'il s'agisse de sens et de
l'esclavagisme moderne de l'entente des
accusés c'est pas croyable que sa mort
que ça ça ne remonte pas à la préfecture
s'est pas envisageable en fait donc je
me suis je me suis dit est-ce que c'est
peut-être pas de là que ça vient je ne
sais pas après ce qui est quand même
frappant aussi c'est que bon on sait
aussi que le point il déteste ça france
insoumise il en fait entre les deux
tours de la ville et ils ont une à
peindre de sortir ouais
démocratie et le crédit c'est le crédit
lui de du titre absolu le titre se
décrédibilise le profondément et pour
longtemps aujourd'hui vous êtes pas ça
vous n'êtes pas sur autre chose ou on
vous attend non là je suis pas du tout
passé à autre chose parce que d'abord le
mal est fait vous allez faire quoi vous
allez alors d'abord je vais je vais
essayer d'obtenir justice pas seulement
pour moi mais pour mes enfants mois de
juin c'est la première fois que mes
enfants sont attirés comme ça à utiliser
dans je pense une dans une opération
voilà une machination contre moi et ça
je ne pardonnerai jamais je ne
pardonnerai jamais que ma fille ce matin
en partant à l'école la dernière a dit a
dit alexis papa c'est vraiment toi qui
viens me chercher à 4h30 je veux pas
être enlevée par quelqu'un qui va
m'amener à paris on part une nounou
imaginaire ou je sais pas quoi elle est
vraiment traumatisé
je n'accepte pas que ma fille de 19 ans
et dû elle-même répondre aux
journalistes de médiapart que j'ai fait
venir chez moi c'est à dire que pour
vraiment moi pour être pour justifier je
l'étais venir chez moi ce matin j'ai
fait visiter toute la maison toutes les
chambres j'ai je les fais faire une
interview fin des zac des questions avec
ma fille de 19 ans c'est je ne
pardonnerai jamais parce que mes enfants
j'essaye je sais que l'adversité
politique elle est forte mais mais mais
mais enfin on essaye de les protéger
avec alexis là ils ont été ils ont été
traînés là dedans et elles ont appris en
plus par évidemment par les réseaux
parce que les grandes salles de 22 ans
et 19 ans elle m'a pris par les réseaux
donc c'est vraiment horrible et donc on
apprend porte plainte pour diffamation
bien sûr contre le point on porte
plainte bien entendu contre à zemmouri
lui même pour les tweets qui l'a fait on
porte plainte également au pénal pour
usurpation d'identité c'est quand même
des gens qui sont fait passer pour moi
notamment en mettant ma photo de profil
dans des captures d'écran est aussi faux
et usage de faux parce que ça va encore
plus loin que le droit de la presse la
scène c'est du crime en fait l'un des
lits et je veux savoir je vais savoir
d'où ça vient je veux savoir pourquoi on
dit que le point savez en fait avait
déjà le dossier mais n'a pas publié la
semaine dernière ça c'est ce que dit le
point cet après midi sur la base d'un
d'un tweet ratés dans dm fail qui a été
publié ce après midi par jean christophe
lagarde qui était mon opposant oui toi
que j'ai battu que j'ai bac en vous ce
dernier non non vous vous avez tous
connus vous êtes-vous fait agresser
enfin la semaine dernière avant date
avant d'être élue la semaine d'après
vous avez cette affaire qui tombe au
sepa que la cdci balle à cette
condamnation serait mentionné émotionnel
cette campagne est là elle fait dur
alors on m'avait dit que c'était dur on
m'avait dit que c'était dur j'avais lu
par exemple un livre de f chefs tels qui
s'appelle le maire et les barbares qui
raconte par le menu ce qu'on reproche à
jean christophe lagarde et ce dont il
est capable vais dire à quel titre est
une circonscription très difficile et
j'ai accepté le défi parce que les gens
n'en peuvent plus là bas ils ont pouvait
plus au bourget à drancy ravonison
pouvait plus et j'ai accepté le défi
mais alors ils m'ont tous fait quoi
auront tout fait c'est à dire les
fectivement le fait de me caser à bout
portant
le fait d'organiser des x pour que je
puisse pas rentrer dans une résidence le
fait de vam vandalisé 6 sur 8 ascenseurs
du centre-ville de bobigny le dimanche
du jour de vote à 17h il ya les gens qui
pouvaient plus des sans détour pour
voter bon c'est derrière nous parce que
j'ai gagné et j'ai en plus bien gagner
juillet min hall 1 ça y est
c'est reparti remerciera gobain merci
merci et je crois moi je dis juste à
tout le monde je comprends les gens qui
ne croient pas les journalistes je veux
croire en la bonne foi de tous les
journalistes qui aujourd'hui dénonce à
zemmouri et ces méthodes là il ya eu une
réaction du snj cgt il ya eu une
réaction de la société des rédacteurs du
point mais je le dis attention attention
les journalistes vous ne pouvez pas
impunément faire ce genre de choses
parce que c'est le crédit de toute la
profession qui est en cause et du coup
c'est notre droit nous d'être informé
parce que nous les citoyens si on ne
croit plus personne ça veut dire qu'on
est mal informé et si on est mal informé
on est en fait livrer à toutes les
manipulations d'où qu'elle vienne des
pouvoirs économiques des pouvoirs
politiques d'où qu'elles viennent on a
besoin d'être informés on est informé
par l'école mais on nie aussi informé au
quotidien par la presse et la qualité de
la presse la déontologie c'est sacré
c'est sacré voilà j'espère peut-être
qu'en tant que député je pourrai
proposer une loi garrido pour la
création par exemple d'un conseil de
déontologie
ce serait vraiment la présente séquence
avec l'assemblée ya pas de voix qui
m'ont passé passé à regarder je vous ai
amené sa série le regardais ma chérie
regardez moi c'est pas pour toi
l'allocution c'est mon écharpe des dons
de nourriture ont l'allocution away
alors vous me prêtez vous voyez bien la
solution pour l'allocution
oui même en bleu blanc et les chars
tricolores ont connu un
mais ce que vous ne savez pas dans
l'ensemble est merdique c'est le bleu au
cou ah ouais et pour les députés et
rouge ok bon et pas ça
[Applaudissements]